don't look at my pic Sims I've got 13
bonafide winners that means you don't
have one then if you got 13 of them I'm
gonna be honest I've got no idea what
I'm doing anymore we're all here for you
it's in your head right now I'm gonna
tell you when it becomes really
important to you you overthink stuff you
know what's really interesting is I go
this is what Sims felt like chasing me
all those years
you think I told Josh one of the things
that I feel like has improved my fix
this year one thing for sure is not
trying to find hidden gems and doing
things like that so what's funny is I
actually sat here this last night and
today and I ran all those games where I
do the deep dive and I go I learned that
the last three by weeks not doing that
[ __ ] yeah yeah just who's the better
team and then he can attest this I went
who do I actually want to bet on I
flipped to from my scores because I was
like I don't want to bet on that team I
just don't want to I don't trust our
quarterback on trust their coach you got
it you have to ask yourself those
questions especially when it comes to
asking the big money beds that's at
least what's something I asked myself
for sure he's stressed as hell right now
yeah but it is not me not having to pick
my hidden gems and doing that I feel
like I've gotten to make a more of a
broader look at games and I'm what was
an example of a hidden gem this season
that you made that you now go I would
never do that again
well not just just you know how I used
to do those videos I mean a picker so I
would get lost and fillings right where
I feel like you'd be like a matchup they
can exploit this third corners actually
lose the overall scope of the team in
the game at times where I was like come
on you knew that but I you know what I
watched that film and I was so worried
about 35 and how he was playing and who
he popped to me and then I kind of lost
my way there so before you give that or
while you give this yeah after you give
where we currently stand could you also
look at how Sims has done just against
the spread we know his guaranteed to
lose was great the whole season just the
last few weeks yeah I have his record
for the whole season I could tally up
the last few weeks if you could do that
afterwards I'll be great but where do we
stand I hope I'm close all right boy so
you're not close laughs go sorry to
report that last week week nine Sims you
made 800 bleacher bucks left go you made
negative forty bleach
box so all right around here on the
season hold on making 800 in a week is
pretty damn good thanks man but I want
to say this before you keep going we'll
read his season total yes ohh on the
season Sims you are at 890 left go you
are at negative 120 records last week
Sims you went 9 and 4 against the spread
left go you went 6 and 7 which brings
our records for the whole season Sims
Congrats you're above 500 your 67-63 and
3 and left go you are 63-67 and 3
someone in the YouTube comments was
asking what the 3 is on the end those
are the pushes so wins losses pushes but
since you're above 500 well I just tally
did this this up on my own yeah since
week 5 right if you've been betting with
Sims you would have made $400 450
dollars
$700 and $800 on all of your bets in
back-to-back weeks that means if you
didn't just do the money lines the
guaranteed to loses if you bet with Sims
all of his bets and took our bleacher
bucks and actually did your own money
you would have made over $2,000 the last
four weeks and I will add 850 that's
1650 you would have made two thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars that's
the ground you've made up because in
Week five you were down fourteen sixty
and now you're up eight ninety right so
if you bet with you every week it's I'm
just glad that it took me beating you
for four years for you to like I'd taken
a lot of credit for the Hat you should I
had to take my gosh just heard me
talking to myself while I was picking
games and I was going through it I said
okay what was left go do today I said
don't bet with your heart bet with your
brain you idiot like I have that's those
things I have to talk to myself
sometimes but I'm just saying you're not
just on a guaranteed to lose heater your
only 2300 Plus heater I'm gonna heat it
and if you guys remember in the
preseason podcast you said I have no
idea what's gonna happen the first two
to three weeks of the season no one
played in the preseason I have no feel
for the teams the first three games of
the preseason and then your heater
started in weak force just like in the
first two three weeks
the line was going nutrients by double
digits all over the place
all of us and then injuries occur and
things a lot of things change all right
guys let's get started here Thursday
Night Football these six and two
Carolina Panthers on the road visiting
the five two and one Pittsburgh Steelers
we previewed this game a little bit
yesterday Sims we're gonna start with
you today spreading this game is
Pittsburgh - three and a half yeah I
mean awesome game you know as if
anybody's listened to our pods here the
last day you know this whole week we've
talked about these are two teams that I
think left Co and I both would agree
that our teams that can win the Super
Bowl
I'm truly intrigued by they have similar
styles right it's about physicality they
both want to impose their will on you
with their offense and defensive line
that's the kind of teams they are they
both have pretty creative offenses too
so this is not like you're boring like
oh we're just gonna run downhill and do
the downhill and do that so I look at
this this is my big question when
Pittsburgh is on offense and Carolina is
on defense these are the questions I
would pose for everybody ken ken
Carolina legitimately cover Pittsburgh
and when I say that cover them yeah
nobody's going to cover Pittsburgh all
game long but you also have to apply
pressure along that way - that scares me
about Carolina I'm not sure they can do
that they're very sound they're very
well coached
I wouldn't think Pittsburgh gets a ton
of big plays tonight the other side of
the ball the Carolina Panthers against
the Pittsburgh Steelers Pittsburgh
Steelers hey they depend on cam Hayward
you know step on to it there front for
just over running the other team's
offensive line think it's gonna be hard
to do
there's some big em effers up there for
the Carolina Panthers also the other
thing that doesn't allow you to tee off
against a team like Carolina is all the
things Norv Turner does on the offensive
side of the ball that's going to take
away some of the aggressive nature of
the Steelers I'm almost there and so
that's I look at that and I look at the
Carolina offense let's go and I know you
and I both like it a whole lot they do a
lot of cool things they got weapons and
of course Cam can throw the ball so
those are the things I like and dislike
about both sides of that matchup I think
really all it comes down to at the end
of the day it's Thursday night okay it's
in Pittsburgh I find this to be a very
evenly matched football game I am going
to put $50 on the Carolina Panthers
but I am picking the Steelers to win the
game 24 to 23 but I only put 50 cuz I
it's Thursday night and they're so
evenly matched and I could see I could
see Pitt going up 28 21 late in the game
or yes I could also see you know the you
know the opposite of that so I did to me
that's the unknown and that's why it's
only 50 all right so let me go back and
forth some things that I find
interesting Carolina's 1 & 2 on the road
this season their only win was Philly
when they were down 17 nothing so
Carolina hasn't been the best road team
now
also think about how they started those
games they were down 24 to 10 I believe
in their first road game 17 nothing down
to Washington yeah 17 nothing down to
Philadelphia so they started those games
down fifty eight to ten yeah wouldn't
shock me if Pittsburgh jumped out early
Pittsburgh is 2 & 2 at home but there to
know in their last two games and they've
outscored Atlanta and Cleveland by 39
points I also wanna say this Carolina
average is 20 points 7 points on the
road 31.6 at home so their offense
doesn't travel Carolina
won seven straight against the AFC yeah
Steelers are one in four against the
spread in our last 5 prime time games
but this is one for one in four in
primetime yes but here's something that
I find really interesting Carolina their
defense is 31st in the red zone and 32nd
in gold to go hmm Pittsburgh's offense
is second in the red zone fifth in gold
to go yeah as I'm watching this game
last night tonight when we're actually
doing this can Carolina get stops in the
red zone yeah when I watch Tennessee
Dallas right where Tennessee was the
number one red zone team it worked
those are the thing you know how I care
about that towards the end of the year
how are you and your backs against the
wall Minnesota so great they sacked
Stafford LA I'm going $50 on Carolina as
well yeah
rarer I have Steelers winning 29:27 sure
I think it's gonna be a little bit
high-scoring I'm just looking at the
Thursday Night Football games lately I'm
going there's been a lot of points going
on the board let's go
but you get it you're given both team
another touchdown over me I think these
teams are so evenly matched and I had
when I was doing the scores in my head I
go damn I got Pittsburgh up 10 points
and then I'm just seeing Cam Newton and
I'm seeing Cam Newton gonna do some Cam
Newton stuff today yeah and I'm just I'm
looking at Christian McCaffrey and Greg
Olson against the middle that defense I
think they'll have some success I think
the short weak hurts Carolina more than
Pittsburgh just because of all the
things they do on offense right the the
all the fake reverses reverses speed
sweeps all that so that that's why I
hate Thursday Night Football is talked
about but go ahead let's go the next one
all right guys next game the seven and
one New Orleans Saints on the road
visiting the five and three Cincinnati
Bengals spread in this game New Orleans
minus five and a half it opened at
Saints minus four and a half so it's
moved up a point Sims over to yep okay
well III alright so Cincinnati's offense
verse the New Orleans Saints defense hey
I don't expect the Cincinnati Bengals to
be able to run on the New Orleans Saints
at a consistent basis certainly not and
and you know hey the Saints t line it
does think that markets Davenport hasn't
been playing guys like Sheldon Rankin's
and some of their inner guy interior
guys have been playing very good
football lately so don't think the
running game goes up
of course I think Cincinnati can throw
the ball on the New Orleans Saints but
you know the thing that concerns me
there is there's no AJ green and huge
yeah that's huge and I do think
Cincinnati's gonna make some plays in
the past game but I don't know if they
can just sit there and say they're gonna
yeah I can't sit here and say they're
gonna torch New Orleans secondary I
think New Orleans has kind of figured
out their formula for what they want to
do on the back end and you know the fact
that I also think New Orleans is gonna
feel pretty confident in the fact that
they can stop the run they're not gonna
have to put themselves in any vulnerable
positions in the past game I think when
I flip over to the other side you know
hey I worry about Cincinnati's defense
it's not good they're caught in between
schemes right they're caught between the
Marvin Lewis Mike Zimmer scheme and
Terrell Terrell Austin who wants to run
the Ravens scheme they don't have the
personnel fit I think
he's trying to do some of what Marvin
wants and I think he's also trying to do
some of what he wants and that's why I
think there are still on pace to let up
more yards in the history of the
football on the defense side of the ball
which is amazing with some of the talent
they have on that team I just can't
imagine hiring a defensive coordinator
that's been running a system for a long
time saying can you change your system
yeah I know hire a guy to run his system
that's just me no I I think that's a
valid point and I don't know if along
the way something got made to where they
were like you know okay for this year
till be getting your personnel and then
we'll change over who knows but that is
a concern for me and I just look at the
Saints offense and I look at it like
this I look at Cincinnati has played
really four complete offenses that I
look at this year okay
the Panthers the Falcons the Steelers
and the Chiefs and they let up 45 28 36
and 31 against those offenses that
scares me to death
and because of that I am putting $300 on
the New Orleans sins because they're
gonna play that saxophone up and
Cincinnati yeah yeah I do I think that
Saints win this game 34 24 34 24 yes so
this is that moment where I go man Sims
is investing a large chunk of his money
into a team that has been cruising
against a team missing their best player
yeah and I go makes a lot of sense
mm-hmm which I put more on this month
know what else I'll say this I'm doing
$50 on New Orleans okay
now gonna put as much as themes but I
tell you what I like the way your hips
taste tastes hips huh this is the 31st
ranked pasty against the 30 second
ranked pass defense Andy Dalton when AJ
Green missed the last five weeks of 2016
they went two and three he had one game
over 300 but he did protect the ball
yeah six touchdowns two interceptions
Bengals are getting John Ross back they
are getting their center Billy price
back there are questions about dark has
Denard the reason that I went a little
bit less emotional went on sunday over
the Rams yeah I know
and now we're going outside right drew
brees the away game we know what
happened that Vikings game ball bounced
their way the Ravens game yeah it took a
little bit of luck there the Giants game
wasn't all smooth sailing the entire
game what no I just I was gonna well I
want to know what's the weather in
Cincinnati on Sunday would be
interesting because I going into your
job am I gonna do my job yeah give me
one sec I don't know if you guys wanted
the weather today so I I do think that
Cincinnati is going to move the ball
yeah a little bit right I have 45 mostly
sunny okay so let me ask you this yeah
so your I you know I was just worried
about the Saints coming off an emotional
winning going on the road against a team
that you know backs against the wall
type of stuff
what a year why are you so confident
because you're not afraid of that I'm
not afraid of that with the New Orleans
Saints because Sean Payton's gonna
coming off a bye I don't know what the
Bengals are exact I don't know either
but I know what they are as far as their
kind of a spotty offense that has
potential but their best player isn't
there and their defense has been bad and
I look at the Saints and go you know
Sean Payton's he's got a red ass the
whole year and I don't think they're
letting up I don't think he's gonna let
up on this team I don't think they can
sit there and go huh we we beat the Rams
we're definitely gonna be the one seat
or the to see the way the NFC is playing
out right now they're gonna play their
ass off they got a there's still
Carolina looming and the Rams you know
they might not lose again you don't know
so they have to continue to push that
and they did Baltimore
there's no letdown in Minnesota they
beat Minnesota there was no lead down
with the Rams this is a different team
with the Saints they're the school I had
was Saints 27:20 right I just for some
reason to think that there's gonna be
some deflected balls and picks that were
right but all right so yeah his first
big money bet on the board I told this
to Josh before we started yeah I'm
thinking because you're so hot right now
about just adopting your big picks as my
love go LOX look man there's no shame in
my game oh hey there shouldn't be it's
like it's like Sean McVeigh stealing to
play who cares - Sean McVeigh of
gambling there it is alright guys next
game at one o'clock yeah 4 & 4 Atlanta
Falcons on a three-game winning streak
visiting the - 6 & 1
Cleveland Brown spread in this game is
Ekans - four and just to get out ahead
of it spread in Cleveland on Sunday
partly cloudy high of 39 so keep it in
mind
Maddie ice that's right it's gonna be
cold yep I think not buying that anymore
I think that shit's done exactly right I
mean last week I really rode that
doesn't matter Ryan outside he can't
function I think I don't think that
thoughts there with the New Orleans
either just because of their run game
and all that anymore now - it's just we
really get impacts true breeze at all I
mean you know he might not be the drew
breeze that we saw last week but they're
still gonna be good enough to where it's
not gonna affect them totally so yeah so
I go into the Atlanta game I think the
first thing I do is I go okay Alana's
Elena's offense
it's clicking right now there's no doubt
about that right the Cleveland Browns
their defense is not good they take too
many chances at time so they can't sit
there and play man-to-man across the
board and to get a little bit like last
week to where I just go Elena has enough
of an offense to exploit zone schemes
they're smart enough with Matt Ryan that
he's not gonna get fooled by Greg
Williams creative blitzes Atlanta can
run the ball sneaky good old line I
worry about all of those things I just
look at that and go man I don't know if
Cleveland can match up with Atlanta
Atlanta's rolling right now and you know
I think Mattie ice is just absolutely on
fire and been ballin
I think when I flip it around to the
other side hey I don't know what to
expect with Cleveland Cleveland can make
plays and move the ball but they always
find a way to screw the drive up somehow
- you know you know you look at the
Steelers game damn they only ended up
with 18 points last week it look good
against the Chiefs but they only ended
up with 21 like when the drives need to
count they can't seem to make them or
they can't seem to punch it in the end
zone when they get down there and they
set up for a field goal whatever it may
be
that scares me this is a complete
offense with the Atlanta Falcons I do
the Atlanta Falcons defense has it going
as well they have found the
mix-and-match of the secondary personnel
the linebackers they want to play their
D line is pretty good I just have a hard
time seeing them you know not
controlling this I think I can't see
them not controlling the game and
because of that I am betting $300 yeah
yeah
Elena coming to town into Cleveland
Brown huh Oh watch out get it Madi Isis
bowling ballin ballin ballin trip and
Payton's bowling bowling bowling oh no
splash drop hey Nick that was a good
stop there man way to go that was so I
really like that Nick is I think I might
be stealing so I am going yes I think
the Falcons win this game 32:21 I think
that hey Cleveland wolf they might match
them in a 1714 early but also I just
look at it like this I think Elena still
looks at themselves as a really good
football team I wrote down there write
this hopeful Falcons and I'm curious
when a team wins a game like they did
over washing yeah and now they're four
and four right does the team go and and
does a team all of a sudden go we need
to step it up like we have a chance at
this yeah I mean they've won three in a
row I think they I think they're a team
that feeds off of energy there that's
what they are it's Dan Quinn it's Pete
Carroll let's go oh yeah we're playing
good yeah here we go and they're kind of
a frontrunner team like that I don't
mean they're frontrunner but they're
battle-tested too and again they have no
room for error they have none Atlanta
has to get in the playoffs as a fifth or
a sixth seed and there's not gonna be
much you can't lose them anymore because
like your Eagles you know they can lose
a few because they're still gonna win
the NFC East right where Elena like I
don't see them catching like at least
New Orleans to win the NFC South yeah so
you're gonna have to have a pretty good
record to be the five or six seed in the
playoffs this year especially with a
team like Carolina Minnesota and the
Bears still looming in that conversation
so I'm excited to see those new pass
rushers for Atlanta again after Baker
Mayfield Falcons are the number one team
in the NFL in third down percentage and
I went back and looked chief Steelers
bucks last three games for the Browns
those three teams converted 55% of their
third downs against Cleveland yeah
Atlanta like you said will be
controlling the ball then I said I got
burned last week about Atlanta running
to that edge I looked it up through the
eighth best team in the NFL out running
off the right tackle makes sense they
averaged six yards a carry off right
tackle the Browns are 24th at defending
that run off the right tackle
think adjust have any comment to the
right tackle right but there is a
running back that I do think could have
a great daily fantasy day sure Duke
Johnson yeah Duke went out had a big old
game against the Kansas City Chiefs he
had nine catches and then Greg Williams
comes out and goes Duke Johnson can do
more right if there's one thing the
Falcons defense lets up a lot it's
underneath catches two running backs and
they allow them to tackle yeah
Washington didn't have Chris Thompson
last week so that whole aspect of their
game was remember got to do it right for
some reason when I came out with the
score I got you second guessing like a
mofo dude I had the Falcons winning 27
to 24 yeah which would have been a
Cleveland cover right but I said you
flipped that crap I am NOT betting on
Cleveland so I bet $50 on it at least
that's the right thought there could
just go I'm not an idiot well don't bet
on a team that you just don't know and
so my thing is is for some reason when I
looked at that game
I went why is it Lana only favored by
four and we have this notion with
Cleveland that they had this great
home-field advantage because they beat
Baltimore I also wanted to ask you one
follow before we move to the next game
when a new coach comes in and I think
Cleveland had a little burst of energy
in the beginning of the Chiefs game they
were kind of going back and forth in us
a guy that bet the Chiefs I was like
this game is a little closer than it
needs to be yeah the second game when
all that emotions gone from the first
what's that second game like it could be
a letdown that's what I was thinkin
definitely can be that's I mean if you
made me guess what it would be my that
my thought would be the first game Greg
Williams comes out it's like we're gonna
change it up yeah but if you still have
the same result right I don't know if
that's a change it up stuff works
anymore I'm with you and the other thing
I always play into this Cleveland has
enough talent on their team to wear like
Elena's gonna watch them on film ago
like oh okay this isn't just a walkover
like they're gonna be more they're gonna
see miles Garrett thinking back we've
better be on our game like there we have
certain players on their team where
they're gonna be you know dot and r dot
in the eyes and crossing the t's just
because they you take notice as you
watch film with them but they're just
not a great team there's certain players
he advanced
about betting against Cleveland in my
mind is just like Washington was able to
get some plays on Atlanta hmm
Cleveland will eventually do something
towards the end of the drive that's just
idiotic exactly and I like betting
against those tips
I know if I de steal one of those two
for a left go lock or do you feel really
confident no I mean I feel pretty good
about both I do I mean I guess I would
the New Orleans wanted to be the one I
feel more confident or the two um that
goes LOX but I don't you buy Chris Simms
like I'd be your sponsor yes I would
love fun next game at one o'clock here
the three and five Detroit Lions on the
road visit the lab three Chicago Bears
spreading this game is Chicago minus six
and a half weather in Chicago on Sunday
high of 40 and it's cloudy Sims you know
Matt Patricia does not like to coach in
the clouds how do you see this one going
oh he doesn't I just made yeah okay um I
think I look at it like this I mean the
Lions the Lions offense okay against the
Bears defense you know the Lions had
troubles last week as we know I mean
pass protection was an issue and pass
protection wasn't totally the issue what
really happened a lot of the times is
nobody was open and he had the whole
Stanford how to hold the ball a little
longer than I think either like and then
of course it got home the sack that
being you know the Bears defense is for
my money it's every bit as good as the
Minnesota Vikings I don't think you're
gonna be able to run on the Bears if
your Detroit Lions okay you know and I
also go Kaleo Mac is back that should be
a big effect for the football game Allen
Robbins an Allen Robinson and also i I
just go you know again I think the
Golden State the Golden Tate Factor is a
thing with Detroit it's one less weapon
in the past game they could say all they
wanted such a thing right that they went
out and looked at receivers because they
openly admitted that TJ Jones was not
the guy they're hoping it was and I
watched a lot of videos from Detroit
Lions fans saying maybe this is good for
the Lions that we like TJ Jones did not
show up last without TJ Jones is not he
can't replace what Golden Tate did you
know people are under valuing what
Golden Tate is as a player so
I look at that and I do worry about
Detroit's you know offense and that side
of the matchup the other side of the
ball yeah I worry about Detroit's
defense too I mean there's there's no
question about it
I mean Detroit's defenses it's men all
over the place you know you can run the
football on them they do let up big
plays in certain games I I don't know
what to expect but I would also say I
don't know necessarily what to expect
with the Bears offense either it's not
the most consistent running machine I've
ever seen either you know really I look
at this game more or not and go Chicago
should win this game the only way they
lose is if Mitchell too risky makes some
stupid mistakes or if they still might
win but it can be comes a lot closer so
it being in Chicago the Bears playing
for something I think the Bears are the
better football team I am betting $50 on
the Chicago Bears oh but I gets a little
scared I mean it scares me there's just
too many unknowns that I don't trust I'm
picking the Bears to win 27 to 17 but I
also could see Matt Stafford driving
down late and scoring a touchdown or
true Biscay messing that up and they get
the short field and that game's a 2724
game that's why I don't bet a lot of
money on that one Golden Tate I went
back and looked at the last four times
he played Chicago was not a big factor
in any of the games
Lions last week IRA kept writing mine
and now my notes man the Lions are
moving the ball against Minnesota then
they get in the red zone and flame out
well the Lions are 29th in the end of in
red zone but Minnesota was second
Chicago is 22nd let's watch in I do
think the Lions are gonna be able to
punch them in right I went back last
year and I watched the highlights of
that Chicago Detroit game in Chicago
because I went how the hell did Detroit
win that game Stafford made some unreal
throws I remember that it was this
combination yeah true Biscay had a
fumbled snap returned for a touchdown
which is the mistake you talked about
right and then it was gala day and
Marvin Jones big plays and that's how I
think this game gets interesting also
Chicago Conor Barth missed a 46-yard
field goal to tie it up the big thing
for me is this I think Chicago is
winning the last ten
times they've played Sims what's the
series record five and five lions are
nine and one are you kidding me
I think the Bears win this game 23 to 21
and I have $100 on Detroit it's a
divisional game there I that was that
Lions definitely gonna beat my bear up
that was a mean lion to me this is a
Chicago team that they go in a buffalo
and try Biscay throws for like 140 and
Jordan Howard runs for 44 but they win
41 and 9 the Bears are not at a point
yet where I hon drew percent trust yeah
I just don't trust them yet I get you
I see try Biscay issues every now and
then but you know what true Biscay
didn't that gain that I remember that
overtime fourth and 13 that was the
first time we saw true Biscay run run
and that was so something about when you
had that coming-of-age moment against
another team I think gives you
confidence I just think this game is a
little bit closer I think there are some
fluke each or Biscay plays that happen I
think six and a half to a team that
you've lost nine of the last 10 times -
yeah I just think it's gonna be closer
it's a it's a three or four point win to
me that's that's why I can totally just
the final nervous now do I feel nervous
well I felt nervous about this game
either way that's weird am i go $50 on
my nervous bets and that's a weird one
to me I don't ever go down to 1010 Ville
like you did I only did 110 Ville good
how's your cafe mocha good good my hot
chocolate was excellent today cooking
it's like since Betts has that in our
building
yeah I love going I do a hot chocolate
in a cafe mocha they're good all right
guys next game two and six Arizona
Cardinals on the road visiting the 8 and
1 Kansas City Chiefs spread in this game
Casey - 16 and a half whether in Kansas
City on Sunday high of 48 partly cloudy
Sims ok largest spread of the season yes
because the Chiefs are eight and one
against the spread and Vegas is like
we're done with this so 60 yes you
bet on this team good luck sweating
seventeen seriously it's awesome and
we're with mr. anti Kansas City better
over here now you had you did bet with
them last one I did that with them
lastly but my big thing with Kansas City
I don't care what team you're bettin on
ya seventeen is insane it is insane it
really is okay where do I even start
with they have like hardly any notes for
this game alright so this is this would
be my synopsis here okay just real quick
I mean Arizona's offense is not good I
mean come on there's no there's no magic
pill here but I will say this a bye week
for this Arizona team I do think is a
good thing okay Byron Leftwich kind of
gets to get his you know formula
formulation down as far as what he wants
to do on the offensive side of the ball
Josh Rosen things like that
of course it is a Kansas City defense
that's not the greatest thing we've ever
seen so you know again I'm not gonna say
that the Arizona Cardinals go up and
down the field but they're gonna make
plays because it's the Chiefs oh they
little plays every week that's just
going to happen and I'm not mad at the
Chiefs for that they should do that they
should be kill or be killed because they
should never have their offense sitting
over there for 10 minutes
um now on the other side of the ball you
know of course nothing can stop Kansas
City absolutely nothing okay I mean
they're they're amazing and I will say
with Steve with Steve Wilkes and what he
does on the defensive side of the ball
I think it's semi matches up a little
bit to have potential to slow down
Kansas City like when I say slow down I
mean like they score 30 instead of 41
like is that kind of thing I'm talking
about they're gonna play zones they're
gonna keep a lot of people in front of
them you know they have a decent pass
rush the Arizona Cardinals I don't think
they're gonna have to a lot people too
pressure all the time obviously I think
Kansas City wins this football game
that's a no-brainer
and I when I brought the score down I
have them winning 38 to 20 so they
covered the spread Wow
I'm betting $100 on the Kansas City
Chiefs bye bye mr. Cardinal did you ever
listen to the slow-mo the half speed of
that discussion oh I did
even a sound drunk stoned it's
incredible yes you're like I I couldn't
go hard though the bye week scares me
and Steve Wilkes I think a lot of him is
the defensive coach he think he can
stymie people at times Arizona has had
moments this season where I've seen
glimmers right now they've also had
Denver Broncos on a short week getting
destroyed but they're also in games and
I also look at Josh Rosen and go I think
he's gonna have some time and when Rosen
has some time we know there's gonna be
some openings with Kansas City to make
some plays yeah the other thing that
excites me is when Byron Leftwich took
over the Cardinals started doing things
that I thought they would do from the
beginning under Mike McCoy David Johnson
ran 30 pass routes last the last time
they played right the most he's run all
season right Larry Fitzgerald finally
got 12 targets he was not getting that
many targets Rickey seals Jones ran 37
routes the most he had run all year and
so they have some weapons on this
offense I just don't know what they were
trying to do with Mike McCoy they were
trying to be a power running team with
David Johnson we're put him out at wide
receiver line him up against one of
those slot corners and let's go to work
yeah I think 17 is a lot since week
three Arizona is for one and one against
the spread I think that Rams game kind
of when they lost 34 to nothing new
things it was also Sam Bradford and I do
think a buy is going to help right I
have $50 on Arizona okay I cover that
69th do you really the Lubuntu do do
even a little cool I had this score as
31 to 16 okay so I had it 15 yeah but
you know it could be 31 a 13 and I lose
this but that's I mean that's the range
I think that's that's the proper range I
I just think that 16 and a half I don't
want to sit there and sweat it out I
would never put a lot of money on
yeah I'm just gonna I'm gonna go come on
Josh Rosen keep it close because the
great thing about taking the underdog in
seventeen is every touchdown feels like
a win right because if Arizona somehow
gets a Patrick Peterson touchdown you go
Kansas City now score 24 and they're
very capable yeah but you know I'm just
praying I'm just praying for points III
hear you it's that flying squirrel was
really cool I was gonna go there was it
still there when you got no but she got
it out of the house but she had my wife
had somebody in the house and I don't
think you said this on the podcast I
didn't say this in the bad guys I said
this when we were taping the show
oh no the flying squirrel all right so
good so she told me this story when she
sees homesick you got a like I got to
tell you this real quick so somebody was
in the house she was talking and she
kept seeing something by our garage
basement stairwell just going up and
down the stairs and at first she just
thought it was one of our cats right
because we have three cats walking
around but she noticed like this thing
was like like literally flying up there
like she was like wait that thing is
like is that real like just up and down
up and down and I guess he was trying to
get out of the house obviously
so she Bali goes to look down there she
closes the basement door cause she's
like man if he goes in the basement door
I mean he might ever get out right right
you never know where he's gonna be or
hide or Nestle and she says the thing
just stood on the stairs and she said it
was like the size of like you know like
a I don't know a big plastic ball like
nothing like nothing gigantic and she
opens some doors and the thing didn't
move it just hit on this like the stairs
like you don't see me here right and
chief I was like she shoosh in the thing
a little flying school thing just went
out and that was it these are the
stories when I think about owning a home
and I think about I don't I deal with
that I think about all the nooks and
crannies where critters come in and you
gotta kill the bugs so yeah it's tough
coming in I'm like I just want to call
the super yeah Ramon get up here man I
got a mouse yeah or you could deal with
those things it's all right all right
guys the next game the seven and two New
England Patriots on the road visiting
the four and four Tennessee Titans
spread in this game is New England minus
six and a half weather in Nashville on
Sunday 52 degrees is the high mostly
cloudy
Sims take it away okay um New England's
offense we think so many Michelle is
going to be back right I mean that's
what they're saying or that's how that I
thought I read but made me and have no
idea okay it doesn't really matter that
much to me because I do think
cordarrelle Patterson has legitimately
found his role as a NFL running back for
the rest of his career and that's what
he should be so you know I look at the
Titans defense hey they have some
creative things that they can do on that
side of the ball also Dean P's Mike
Vrabel there's familial familiarity
there I don't he still don't know if I
spit that out right you know but you
know I look at teams that when you say
familiarity yeah there it is say famille
familiarity extra l in there somewhere
familiar yeah it's a tough one
but I do hey listen I don't think
anything can stop New England's offense
really I put them up there in the class
of the Rams and the Chiefs just they get
what they need to get to win the game it
doesn't really matter if they have to
get 28 then they get 28 if they have to
get 24 they're gonna get 24 when they
need to get there whatever it may be but
Dean pieces Dean pieces history I'm
gonna say and Mike Vrabel history it
scares me a little bit I'm not gonna lie
I flip it over to the other side and I
still have no faith in the Titans
defense I'm not gonna be fooled by what
I'm offense I'm not gonna be fooled by
what I saw last week yet I'm not saying
I'm not yet exactly right I'm not buying
me that was like Oh Mariota faked
something I know I'm not gonna buy a new
isolation Corey Davis throws across the
middle exactly right what was that I
thought about that no I know nothing
creative nothing that I'm gonna hang my
hat on yes so I think all those I take
into account you know I do envision the
New England Patriots of course winning
this football game
I guess the Dean peace factor Mike
Vrabel factor at being in Tennessee
scares me from going hard on this game
in any shape way or form you know hey I
will say this to the Titans
you know Malcom Butler and company they
can play man I don't wanna make a living
right
you don't want to make a living in it
but they can play man on given the given
snaps especially those third and four
plays where New England could be so
dangerous and basically unstoppable to
where they might get off the field so at
the end of the day what I'm telling you
is a bet a hundred dollars on the New
England Patriots go sacks Oh wicked hot
chowder is it I don't know is it the red
or the white chowder nobody I know I
can't do the cheddar brilli I read
better I think if I'm getting read I'd
rather get minestrone oh that's true
you're right I probably would chew I
think red New England clam chowder is
bootleg minestrone soup
I guess you're I don't even know if I've
had bred New England clam chowder I've
said you liked it well I know I said I
don't know Jess you're I go you go
I do like red chowder and now you're
gonna say you do I've never had either
you're gonna live on a betting advice
from a guy that doesn't I've never had
either that's what I should have said
I've never had either chowders you know
I'm shadow white no but I'm just saying
if I did the red okay you know then
Boston yeah there is not many things
better than a creamy New England clam
chowder with a little bit of cracker in
there yeah and maybe you get a little of
some clam well yeah I don't like clams
that's the one problem that we're gonna
have a big issue for clam chowder and I
have crackers don't like crackers okay I
was gonna say that I'd like to find one
game each week where we make like a food
bet or something oh I gotta do something
and then if I win you got to try
something and you eating some form of
shellfish it'd be incredible because
when it comes to texture I knew and I
get weirded out sometimes but I am
chowder and then the white cream it just
don't don't sound good to me write it
down for us left clam chowder
I do like just so you know 31 21 Pat's
okay so I have a covering to spread by
three and a half points I just there's a
few things I didn't trust like so the
thing that scared me about the Patriots
is I do think they're a different team
on the road I look at their team and I
go alright you know they really
struggled against Buffalo for most of it
I'm gonna alert right now that Rex
Burkhead is back at practice it may be
eligible in a few weeks but anyway
Buffalo a little bit sloppy the Chicago
game their defense wasn't really up to
par yeah the Lions they lost
Jacksonville they lost so sometimes New
England is not that great at on the road
when I did my score I came out with
Patriots 24 Titans 19 okay
which would be a Titans cover yeah and I
said flip that because I do not want to
bet on the Titans and then I looked and
tell me how much this plays a part
because I know that you always tell me
the past doesn't matter yeah the last
five times that New England has played
Tennessee they've been a disaster
they've beaten them by an average of 29
points a game that doesn't matter in
this one because of rebel and Dean P yes
because that was Jeff Fisher and those
teams not Jeff Fisher well maybe not the
last time they played but the times
before that it was I'm saying I'm just
saying like they get destroyed yeah I
can't imagine Marcus Mariota having that
much success Kenny I can't imagine them
scoring that many points but New England
will allow some yards and all that but I
didn't come away from new Tennessee
Dallas going on impressed with Tennessee
I came away going Dallas blew some
really big opportunity right but I'm
gonna put $50 on New England I'm not
really going it's one of my favorite
songs though more than a feeling by bass
that was the guitar hero song that I
would destroy that was your nominal
guitar bass guitar hero because you'd be
like Barry that's good song that's an
amazing voice whoever that guy is but
yeah I'm going $50.00 on New England
just because I'm afraid of them on the
road coming off a I don't know like yeah
I I hear yeah that's why I didn't go
hard I feel like they're gonna win the
game I went a hundred cuz I felt
somewhat good about it but I'm not a
good enough to put a big chunk of my
fellow game scared me yeah I know I I
get you Buffalo's D is really good
though what the hell am i betting on
all right guys next game what are you so
wrong there what's so wrong about what
do you mean you bet this nah you just
put your big money in on some smart
games now I'm a little nervous that's
all Hey the locks are what matter get
the locks right get the locks right okay
next game here on the one o'clock slate
5 & 3 Washington on the road visiting
the 3 & 5 Tampa Bay Buccaneers
spreading this game Tampa Bay minus
three and the weather on Sunday in
Florida high of 83 early cloudy 67
percent humidity seven mile an hour
winds coming out of the Northeast little
breeze mmm yeah okay so um alright I'll
start here I'll start with Tampa's
offense first a Redskins defense because
I think that's really the marquee
matchup of the football game I mean I
just look at again like this a little
bit like last week's matchup for the
Redskins where I just go hey the
Redskins defense there's a lot I like
you know that certainly but primarily a
zone defensive football team and I look
at the Bucs and go
they have enough offense to move the
ball against zones they have all the
right plays they have all the zone
beaters and they can do that you know
they move the ball in the Pittsburgh
Steelers they play a ton of zone they
they have that within their deals like a
big Adam Humphries case but it
definitely could be so those type of
guys and you know deep end cuts over the
middle to Mike Evans and you know OJ
Howard and the seam route and things
like that that's where I envisioned them
so and also I look at the Redskins they
don't have a great pass rush what you
know Tampa Bay can protect the passer
you know they're not horrible they got
some big guys up there so I look at that
and go okay Fitzpatrick's in half this
time and I do think at times when uh ski
could panic a little bit because he goes
damn we can't get there this week and he
blitz that's what happened a few times
last week he finally was like damn I
can't take it I'm sick of watching Matt
Ryan sit back there and make a move and
then he throws a play you know open into
my zone coverage and it's a first down
so I look at from that aspect to go I do
think Tampa Bay can move the ball on
this Redskins defense which is still
good but not great okay then I go on to
the other side of the ball and Tampa's
defense of course is a dumpster fire as
well I mean we know that but this is
again a lot like last week I go this is
not the offense that necessarily always
takes you know can take advantage of
dumpster fires they're not explosive in
the pass game they're not going to
change this week they lost Paul
Richardson and they lost three what is
trend Williams playing we don't even
know you
no he's out for like a month is he up
for a month for sure okay so so you'll
notice with a shirt no loo that Morgan
Moses missed practice on Wednesday with
an a knee issue right so he said that
Chris Thompson and Jamison crowd cells
down so with a rib Jamison crowded with
an ankle that's I mean that all that all
of that scares the hell out of me so
because of that I am going $50 on the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
yo-oh yo-oh with a pirate's land for me
I just look at I'm only going 50 because
I don't trust either one of these teams
I'm not gonna trust the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers I pick Tampa to win the game
27 23 so they're covering by one point
two straight games for Tampa Bay where
they're down and they come roaring back
Bengals game where Fitzpatrick came in
and almost took it to overtime Panthers
they came back and scored like 21
unanswered points they're gonna start
faster at home because they started fast
at home pretty much every game started
up on Philadelphia 27 to 7 got that 7o
lead on pittsburgh was up 16 to 2 on
Cleveland they come out a little bit
faster at home
I do think Washington's D will bounce
back after last week I don't think it
could be 38 points bad right
Tampa B doesn't have a running attack
like Atlanta does to make them worry
about both yeah that's good but I would
also say maybe we got a little hyped up
on Washington because they slowed down
the Giants and the Cowboys and really
those offenses were learning aren't that
great sure Tampa Bay's defense last in
red zone worst an interception rate
worst in points per game 30th against
the pass and that's why I kind of go
this game is a little scary to me yeah
also the reason that this is really
scary to me is turnovers yeah Washington
is fifth best they've only turned the
ball over seven times only seven
giveaways yeah Tampa Bay has the worst
turnover margin in the NFL - 15 and
they've only taken the ball away six so
here I have a team in Tampa that has
better athletes a better offense and
that should put up more points but
they're more prone to turn the ball over
and Alex Smith is not going to
turn it over I see this game 27:22
Tampa Bay I'm putting $50 on the Tampa
Bay but yep
alright so we're right in line there's
lockstep but I could totally see this
being a game that Tampa had control over
and then they throw an interception or
they lose a fumble and Alex Smith makes
one throw to Jordan Reed and they lose
this game instead of winning 27 22 they
lose 22 to 20 right I could I don't want
to bet on Tampa because I have no idea
what they're doing and I don't want to
bet on Washington because in the words
of Joe who the hell knows yes they're
manic yes so I don't really know I get
you there let's go to the next game it
is going to be a great game for Josh to
leave Buffalo at the Jets possibly Josh
Allen will be starting limited practice
and we know that Sam Darnell is not
starting so we don't get the battle of
the rookie quarterbacks right it might
be Josh Allen against Josh McCown yeah
did not practice a noon wah-wah beat
Ravi Anderson Tremaine Johnson is now
limited in practice so maybe we'll see
him play but this is two teams at the
bottom of the AFC East and likely at the
top of the draft yeah I mean two good
defenses I think that's where I start
this isn't being a defensive struggle
all the way I mean this could be nine
six it could be twelve nine I'm picking
to be sixteen thirteen I am picking it
to be 2012 so I just look at it like
this I I I'm guessing you made me bet I
think Josh Allen's going to play I think
they're gonna hope he does play I have a
hard time thinking that the Jets are
gonna move the ball a whole lot on
Buffalo's defense Buffalo is extremely
sound why not but if you're gonna play
Josh against the Jets yeah why not sit
him right and then take the bye week oh
they had the bye week next and then rest
him up for when he has to host
Jacksonville yeah okay sure uh yeah I
mean yet listen that's maybe what some
playing time against the team where if
he throws one touchdown they might win I
think they just look at it like that
they still want to get him out there
this is a team that maybe they look at
they win gatorman right exactly and
that's the other issue exactly right
they're looking at and going to him
mean Josh we hope you can play because
we have two other guys here that is not
gonna get it done so but I have also no
faith that the Buffalo offense is going
to be able to move the ball and the Jets
defense to I respect the Jets defense
they're gonna the Jets defense yeah I
mean do a quick run down ninth and
interception rate right second in
getting teams off the field on third
down fifth in the red zone 13th against
the pass
yeah now Buffalo not great in those
other metrics 20 20 and 24 and
interception third down in red zone but
they're third against the past
yeah and eleventh against the run yeah I
mean I think you know the bad stats for
Buffalo are really just because their
offense puts them in such bad spots all
the time they're on the field too much
they're just worn out they're gonna damn
we were just out here 40 seconds ago and
then we're back out here again
oh it's 40 seconds later and we're back
out here as yeah but buffalo cover I
have I do I have Buffalo covering I'll
get to that I am going $50 on the
Buffalo Bills but I think it's going to
be Jets winning the game 16 to 13 I have
the Jets winning the game 20 to 12 so I
have a jet cover right yeah I trust Josh
McCown more than anybody else there yeah
because I feel like this is going to be
neither team's offense really does
anything and I go which one of these
teams is more likely to throw mistakes
to the other team and give the other
team short fields and I think josh is
very self-aware at this point of his
career now I'm saying this Josh McCown
also throw some dumb pass yes but I
gotta think he has the awareness to not
do it to know just playing and you don't
need to take any chance and I know it's
easy to crap all over Todd Bowles right
now but tabbles and that defense has
been really good yeah so I think it's a
lot better than people realize it is
it's the same thing like with them with
Buffalo just their their offenses put
them in so many tough positions it's
hard to overcome it all the time all
right so our only difference is thus far
is I'm taking the Jets you're taking
Buffalo I'm taking Arizona and the
points you're taking Kansas City and
you're laying the wood and then I'm
taking Detroit and you're taking Chicago
yeah all right guys next game on the
schedule here the Jacksonville Jaguars 3
& 5 on the
visiting the Indianapolis Colts also at
3:00 and 5:00 spread in this game is
Colts - three cities will go over you
first okay so we'll start with the Jags
offense I mean the Colts defense it's
certainly nothing special or brag about
it's got a lot of potential for future
years and I like what they're building
there and all those things
yeah it really do they got a lot of
great front seven pieces safety place
pieces all those things so it's exciting
for the future but you know there's
still not a special defense they're
sound you know the Albert ever Phyllis
is really he's a good detailed coach and
they have a few little creative things
they do every week but they don't overdo
it they kind of just go this is what we
play and we're gonna be really good at
it we're gonna hustle and make tackles
and not blow any assignments which I
respect and just the right amount
creativeness now you know what I look
about yeah of course the Colts pass
defense is not very good well I don't
look at the Jaguars as being the type of
offense it's just gonna totally exploit
that the other thing though I got to say
here is the Jacksonville Jaguars their
best player is back for the on the
offensive side of the ball and that's
Leonard fournette
and the fact that he's back I got to
think they're gonna ride the big man big
time in this game and try to get back to
what Jacksonville does right DJ is back
to right so to get to get to that like
just control the ball the defense gets
to stay fresh and they get to fly around
like a bunch of maniacs now on the other
side of the ball I'll say this the the
Colts versus the Jags defense an
interesting matchup I do think I do
think that the Colts offense matches up
pretty well with the Jacksonville
defense the Jackson the Colts Alma's the
lion is no slouch anymore your
Jacksonville is not just gonna steamroll
them up front and when you don't
steamroll up front Andrew Luck he'll sit
there like captain Andrew and he will
throw the ball all over the field
now Jacksonville's defense is still
freaky good and they're gonna be foaming
at the frickin mouth and at the freakin
move so my long story short here long
story coming to an end guys betting $50
on the Jacksonville Jaguars
talk about it talk about it I'm betting
$50 I think they're gonna win the game
23 to 19 but I'm only betting 50 I don't
feel confident
I got a seed Jacksonville's offense
actually get back to what Jacksonville
offense was last year before I put money
on you know that side of the ball and
like I said [ __ ] Andrew Luck is good
I don't know what anybody else wants to
say about it he will sit in the pocket
they can run the ball a little bit too
and he scares me so that's why I'm not
going a lot of money on this game I
completely understand that he scares you
here's the thing he's favored by three I
know he's not an under Dino
I love luck as an underdog I not a huge
fan sometimes as a favorite why because
the Colts didn't get a turn did not turn
over the ball once against Oakland or
Buffalo right that's not gonna continue
Locke is gonna be feeling himself Luck's
gonna be throwing it all over the place
this is one of my left go red light
specials I saw this and that buzzer went
off and I said mama
there goes that man Jacksonville has
been sitting around for two weeks
getting [ __ ] on yeah
your quarterback more importantly your
defense stinks you know what I did this
week what did you do left huh
I picked up Jacksonville's defense on
fantasy hmm our own Matt camp fantasy
expert says but their plan and your luck
and I said I don't care because the rest
of this season
I didn't think Jacksonville could get
external motivation I thought they'd
have to battle being the favorite there
suddenly the underdog I went and checked
out how Blake bortles has done the last
few times that he's played in Indy
because he's not great on the road right
last time you played 330 yards one
touchdown no interceptions came before
that 301 yards one touchdown no
interception game before that 298 yards
one touchdown interception I'll also say
this last six times these teams at play
hmm Jacksonville is 6a now against the
spread but
that's not the reason I like it this is
Leonard fournette stomp it on soles yep
this is Jalen Ramsey pick six
this is Jacksonville 30 Indianapolis 16
and I'm putting 200 bleacher bucks on
the Jacksonville jet
I'm not mad at your logic also this is
the other thing that I'm factoring in
yeah for two weeks right the
Indianapolis Colts have been told they
might have the best offensive line the
NFL right coming off a week in which
they stonewalled the Oakland Raiders
that's right the worst pass rush in the
NFL 30 second and sacks they're doing
interviews on Sims and left Co they get
a week off to just gloat about it Andrew
Luck's talking about being protected
they don't even know what's coming into
town I disagree with you there they know
exactly what's coming into town they've
played them and they're gonna be turning
the film will go oh [ __ ] it's these guys
again they're coming into town quick
Nelson has never faced the line with
your brain and Smith has never faced
right
they have never faced the Jacksonville
Jaguars coleus Campbell is gonna go
Quinton you're pretty good and Quinton's
gonna look up slowly and go holy crap
hey Julius what's up man doesn't get
scary don't say that but I just I don't
know why I know why I know what I
believe that Jacksonville with Doug
Marrone
yeah I'm Coughlin and all these guys it
is batten down the hatches
it is all systems go and I'm gonna be
betting on Jacksonville a lot in the
coming weeks because I think that they
are about to start clicking I just got
to see it first
I couldn't guy I didn't have the guts to
do sometimes in gambling yeah I just
can't see Jacksonville losing five in a
row and one to the Indianapolis Colts I
just don't see it yeah it's not the
season they're gonna how do you think it
helps the Colts seizures other things I
just thought there's your food for
thought for anybody listening do you
think it helps the cults that
you know the Eagles just play them so
they got to see what the Eagles did on
the offensive side of balls again check
so maybe it helps Jacksonville I don't
know I'm just saying either way also
another thing I'll just throw over food
to talk to I don't know the answers to
these I just think these are a little
interesting things I think about like
the Cowboys their defense very similar
to what the Colts run on defense so I
just think of those things and go who
would that be an advantage of there was
too many unknowns for me to bet money on
it that's why but my my heart and brain
combination said ooh
this is ridiculous Jacksonville's gonna
win this game and the Colts are favorite
yeah but then I said then you go leave I
have to see my brain and eyes have to
see the Jags oh yeah I want to jump on
this early I want to jump on the Jaguars
early yeah a lot of food for thought
being thrown around this studio yeah he
went he went he went just some food for
thought things to think about stuff that
I'm mulling over ba ba ba and I like a
answer that was the same thing four
times in a row foods for thought okay
moving on to the late afternoon games
here 405 the six and to LA Chargers on
the road visiting the one and seven
Oakland Raiders spread in this game
Chargers - nine and a half whether in
Oakland on Sunday high of 71 and Sonny
Sims do you think we could convince
bleacher Port to let us all live in
California now I don't want to live in
California I don't like what seasons I
love an outside right nice village too
much all right me and Nick are going to
California get the [ __ ] out of here
happy no I like the seasons right now I
love the Northeast it's my favorite time
of the year it's the trees are a plenty
full of beautiful moves or everywhere
they are it's full of it I love all of
those things but then I'd like to wake
up to sunny 70° and a beach gets
overrated gets old take it away Sims I
leave the worst places I leave my
apartment and there's a guy go watch out
for that yeah here in LA and someone's
like hi how are you would you like a
pokeball okay listen there's a lot of
positives I mean I'm not gonna if I got
stuck in LA oh man I'm stuck in LA that
stinks okay
getting Walker getting back to business
here
start with the Oakland offense first the
Chargers defense Oakland I don't know
what to think with Oakland right now I
really don't to say I really don't know
what to say
I mean Oakland can throw the ball and do
those type of things and do it
consistently most weeks I know last week
that's not the case let's just a wipe
last week out of our brains it's not
great pass protection you know the
Chargers defense is not overly
complicated they're definitely better in
this matchup
does Oakland continue to be a dumpster
fire did last week's ass-whooping wake
them up enough to say okay we're gonna
put a spirited effort out here there's
just so many unknowns with that part you
know and then I go to the other side and
damn when the Oakland Raiders got to
play complete offenses it's big trouble
I mean it really is and that scares me
too I mean the charges can run the ball
and of course we know they can throw the
ball and Oakland you know the scheme is
not overwhelming that the the talent on
the field is not overwhelming and that
of course scares the crap out of me so I
guess what I'm saying is the big
question is Oakland's offense and what
can they do are they gonna be able to
move the ball are they gonna be able to
protect you know are we gonna see the
Oakland offense who did some good things
you know through the first you know half
of the year here to this point I I don't
know I don't know so I'm betting $100 on
the Los Angeles chargers I'm only going
100 man that's he's fried that guy that
Raider is fried but I dared to do that
one for gridiron Heights
yeah I was Ryan Fitzpatrick and I was
taking movie tickets and Bill Belichick
came in you know in Star Wars when the
guy like electrocutes people yeah and
they had me in the audio booth doing
electrocuted person sounds for about 15
minutes anyway they be like okay be
electrocuted I'm like yeah it's a lot of
fun I can try it be electrocuted about
your kid
Josh you traffic maybe some blood anyway
I showed my kids taken the other day and
he does that to one of them I have a
certain yes yeah I showed him then they
electrocute the guy in the chair it's
good good thing to show your
eight-year-old he loved it
he's seen worse would you show him last
year I mean take it out of explain to
them they were stealing women and having
sex with these women too as they were
drugging so that was a little bit of a
topic oh you had the time we've had the
talk
okay wait last point I picked the
charges to win 38:24 I'm putting a
hundred dollars on the Chargers
obviously I guess I'm just scared that I
what scares me is that they has a Jewish
that and this scares you is that when
the Chargers played the Raiders the
Raiders were in that game they were and
they had a few red zone turnover right
and the history of the Chargers Raiders
rivalry is really freakin weird right a
lot of underdogs win these and it was
sort of like you know these Raiders got
pride right I don't know I got an alert
about an hour ago my bleach report at
mmm an article from tied up oh good
friend yeah I'm gonna read three
sentences here
sift through the remains and it's about
the Raiders yeah sift through the
remains and there are some players who
are trying to believe but there's no
doubt about it the destruction is taking
a toll one Raiders vent looks around an
empty locker room and shakes his head
quote they're trying to find a reason to
get anybody out of here what I believe
we saw last Thursday was the death of
the Raiders 2018 season there's nothing
to play for all hope is lost and I think
just like Greg Williams speeches won't
resonate as much in week two I don't
know if anyone's listening to Gruden
right now yeah I have this game as 41 to
17 chargers and I'm going 300 bleacher
bucks on the charger
[Music]
judges judge I'm going 41:17 Chargers
yeah it's I couldn't believe this I
thought they were gonna get the Chiefs
spread like I thought of the two they
would get the Chiefs spread I mean I
know I mean I don't know if they're
gonna be able to tackle Melvin Gordon
there's there's a lot of unknowns there
third there definitely is I know I don't
know what to say
I watched Jon Gruden arguing with his
defensive coordinator and I watched Mull
I watched Nick Mullens and the Niners
offense tear apart that defense yeah and
I don't think that Phillip Rivers Melvin
Gordon
Melvin Ingram Keenan Allen Trevor Wow
Tyrell Williams like all those guys
Rivers - I said Phillip Rivers Ribble's
you said no I wasn't sure who a position
he played rebels yeah so I I just I know
that some crazy things can happen let's
go yeah I mean I'm not arguing with you
there man I get it
I just I'm I'm wimping out because one
team got embarrassed and she lacks so
bad in their home mile and I'm going
maybe they put a good effort together
and I don't have all the faith in the
world and the Chargers deepa the other
reason that I had confidence in the
Chargers defense was when I watched that
Seattle game until Russell Wilson was in
like survival mode in the last eight
minutes of that game yeah they couldn't
do anything and they have better pieces
than the Raiders do yeah they couldn't
run the ball Russell Wilson couldn't
throw the ball he was under attack the
entire game I also think the Chargers
are in that perfect mode right now were
they're still being doubted even though
they're six and two and they're fully
used to playing without Joey Bosa which
is gonna be amazing when he comes back
but when you're eight weeks in and
you've moved on it's no longer a Miss
now it's just gonna be a bonus when he
comes back I I really hope this is a
blowout because I'd like to not have to
pay attention to it when the other games
right I would think it is a blowout I
would you did you said they'd win by 14
I know I know but I just scares me that
you know it might be 38 17 and they get
to garbage
time touchdown let's pay attention to
this we have three straight nine and a
half point spreads let's see the games
in which Sims goes it just scares me or
I feel confident sure this one wasn't I
feel confident that you still said it
scares ya it does it scares me just in
this yeah I do
let's see what happens right so here we
go to Lambeau Field
alright guys next game on the schedule
here the four and for Seattle Seahawks
taking on the eight and one LA Rams at
throw 25 spread in this game is LA -
nine and a half whether in LA on Sunday
similar to Oakland 76 degrees and sunny
Sims 7 would you say 76 and sunny in LA
okay sorry I'm on the wrong game so
although that's okay take your time
Packers I win a game ahead I just like
to pull up the schedules as we're doing
this just just to have references and
things that I've already thought about
so I can just go there okay I'm almost
ready like that charger so okay here we
go
okay um start with the Rams offense
versus Seahawks teeth yeah yeah yeah I
mean of course the rims you know like
the Patriots like the Chiefs it's an
unstoppable force
it really is it's just it ain't it ain't
about you know if it's just when it's
when did they start clicking when do
they start flying down the field doing
all those type of things as we talked
about last week I do think Seattle's
defense has been overrated because they
got the benefit of playing some you know
not complete offenses early in the year
that's skewed the stats you know always
scares me when a team you know doesn't
have great talent I think the future
looked good in Seattle and they're
building something but the talents not
great there yet they're also young and
they're playing against the Rams of
course
and when kid genius knows the defense or
two you're gonna line up and the
majority of the game that always scares
me it definitely does now to flip it
around on the other side you know the
Rams defense a little bit all over the
place right now you know I'm willing to
admit that and also I'd like to say just
like the Chiefs the Ramsey feds
shouldn't be top five in football and
yards allowed they should be killed or
be killed that's what they are
again there's no
the Rams offense beyond the sideline for
a 10-minute Drive it should be Aaron
Donnell makes a sack to get off the
field on third down so they're the rare
team where you went the defensive
coordinator to all-out blitz occasions
be a great be aggressive and I think
that's what they do I think they
understand the 100 percent so that's
what I respect about them they
understand the full scope of what their
team is and how they should play a style
of football cago Bears should never be
all out blitzing no right right they
should be playing yes the more
conservative notion playing yes a
complete game in a different fashion so
I look at that now I of course Sims
always scared with the new Rams run
defense to a degree you know that I do
think this is a big hulking old line of
the Seattle Seahawks I also think the
Rams defense is gonna be a little bit
pissed by the way they played last week
I do
Russell Wilson of course is always scary
to me as well and especially with a Rams
defense that has been letting up some
big plays as we all know so what I got
to down to at the end of the day is this
is the bottom line - and this is what
scared me from not showing a big it's
just the this this is it right here this
is it Seattle is in must have to win a
football game because again they're not
gonna win the West we know that and they
have to keep paisas pace with the likes
of the like we've talked about the
Panthers the Panthers the Vikings you
know even the Bears who they lost to who
were actually leading the NFC North
right now so if they lose this game I
just look at it and go man they're in
deep crap to try to get that fifth or
sixth seed in the NFC playoffs
so I $50 on the Rams man and I'm picking
the game to be 34 to 24 but you know I
just scares me at Seattle Seahawks it's
Russell Wilson and it's desperation time
and that's where I get scared I think
that the fact that the Seahawks went
blow to blow with them a few weeks ago
33 to 31 you look at the last few years
Seattle has gone into LA yeah and done
really really well there's one two years
ago right I think they won last I think
they won the last two years so last year
they go in to see they go in re week
five and they win 16 to 10 yeah
and then two years ago Seattle they lost
to LA nine to three so for some reason
when the games in LA it's a very
low-scoring game the last two years at
least right I look at this and I really
hope Kris Carson can play him and Doug
Baldwin both missed practice on
Wednesday yeah but the Rams to me I have
them winning this game 29 to 21 and I am
putting $100 on Seattle to cover this
spread I think that the Rams look at the
size of its wingspan that must be a land
Hawk no you know it's a Seahawk oh
thanks um
I just think of these 9.5 spreads this
is the one where I go it's a you know
Chargers Raiders or a divisional match
it but one team is dead but it's the
Seahawks fighting tooth and nail yeah
they're not gonna lose the field
position battle they got good special
teams to make this work and constantly
put the Rams back do I think the Rams
are gonna get off of course I think the
Rams are gonna get off do I think that
Seattle is going to I think Seattle is
going to out fossil fossil in fossil I
think yeah you don't have fossil fossil
in fossil let me tell you something
consider yourself fossilized I think
Seattle brings out all the fakes yeah I
think you're getting the deep passes on
the play-action a Tyler Lockett I think
you're getting a fake punt pass I think
Pete Carroll is going into the house
that he built USC and he's going to
unload everything
I think the Rams though are too good in
the end but I think it's closer than
nine and a half yeah I mean the Rams are
like four and five against the spread
this year they're getting the spreads
that the Chiefs got this week right like
the 16 and a half Stein I just think
nine and a half us too much for a game
that you just beat them by two yeah on a
fourth and one dive to end the game
right now you're happy
yeah so I'm going to hunch
there on see ya I'm not matter either
alright guys last game of the afternoon
here what's the last time you were mad
at me for a pick last week when you
tried to tell me the rams over the so
yeah if this actually did get mad at
each other well no I don't ever get mad
at Beth stuff like what's really
incredible I realized this before last
week's pick
I spent the night before doing all the
one o'clock so I thought I'll have time
in the morning to do my four o'clock
Sunday night and Monday Night Football I
went one in four in all of those games
the only one I got right was Houston and
I easily could have lost that and you
pick those up morning you're saying I
picked Seattle the Rams Green Bay and
Dallas I lost all of them I think the
moment that got you mad was when left go
goes I think this is the game where Sean
Payton is looking across the field and
he sees Sean McMann right exactly right
maybe I'm not the best that is the boy
that got the fire my ass why are you you
were like you were not the only people
let's just say Saints fans are in my
image and that's why I apologized to him
on Monday right
I also we didn't go back and what was
the game I changed Lashley in a soda
you took Minnesota from not covering -
covering so I did that I did and you hit
yeah because it was 24 9 right yeah
alright I just wanted to I was wondering
which one of us alright so next game
here I haven't even said third of the
nine and a half points spread four
o'clock game for 25 on Sunday the five
and for Miami Dolphins visiting the
three four and one Green Bay Packers
spread in this game Packers - nine and a
half left go you asked me before the pod
whether and Green Bay on Sunday high of
37 Oh howdy it's gonna be cold Rock
November bro vembur and remember for 25
game temperatures are going down with
locker room at halftime it could be in
the 20s yeah I love this game this is uh
this is an interesting one um okay I
don't know I obviously think the Packers
are gonna win I'm just gonna say that we
all know that I look at the the Dolphins
defense first of all yeah exactly right
not in love with the Dolphins defense
but as you know I'm not in love with the
Packers offense either no you're it's
one guy making magic that's all I look
at Vontae Adams go out run save you and
how right exactly right it's gonna be
there when can we get the double move or
when can we buy time for Rodgers to
throw a 45-yard piss missile down the
field when will that happen now the one
thing you got to remember with the Miami
Dolphins they do have a little bit speed
on the edge of their defense as far as
pass rushers they don't have great d
tackles they don't have enough big
people and run stopping linebackers so I
do think the Packers gonna be able to
run the ball oh they'll be able to run
the ball but the Packers are just not
gonna blow anybody away running the
football I did appreciate that Packers
Patriots game yeah they really stuck
with a try to their best and and I will
say that about the Packers this year
yeah Patton on defense
yeah and just their philosophy on
offense right has been improved yes
hundred percent I don't need to talk
about Patton just destroying Brock
Osweiler this week well yeah that's the
other side right yeah I mean it
definitely is and I look at that side of
the ball I I think this that a course
Green Bay has the advantage here Green
Bag can play aggressive defense at times
now where I would say I obviously think
they're the better unit but what I also
would say what scares me at times is
because Green Bay will play man-to-man
and do things like that and GaSe is
smart about being not overly complicated
against defenses that do a lot of
different things he might be simple and
skip to this stick to the script all
that he'll try to run the football as
well you know I like I said I expect
Green Bay to win the game but I don't
know there's something that tells me
that you know this nine and a half is a
lot it's a lot of points for the Green
Bay Packers I mean you know it's just
because again it's coming down to one
guy and a guy like his avian Hauer can
slow down you know Davante Adams at
times or were even a Valdez scantling so
I put $50 only $50 on the Green Bay
Packers because I think the Dolphins at
least have some toughness to them more
times than not I don't expect them to
blow coverages or do anything like that
because I don't think that the Packers
offense is created enough to ever blow a
coverage like we saw them do against the
Houston Texans when they were owned
ran big deep crossers I picked the
Packers to win 3220 they're covering the
spread but I just don't feel good about
it nine and a half was a little too much
for for my blood I the Packers are three
oh and one at home the Dolphins are one
and three on the road and next week the
Dolphins got a bye they got a by next
week they're super excited for it they
all have their vacations planned and
they're going to nice cold crisp brisk
Green Bay where Aaron Rodgers and his
cheese head teammates have lost two in a
row destroyed at the end of the game by
a fumble that cost them a chance to
watch their great savior lead them to
the promised land and then being
outdueled by Tom Brady where they
another fumble that their their great
savior was leading them down the field
at that point last time the Dolphins
played on the road they lost by 19 to
the Texans the time before that they led
up 27 straight points to lose to the
Cincinnati Bengals the time before that
they lost by 31 points to the New
England Patriots Brock Osweiler has been
slowly decomposing in front of our eyes
the dream of his he does this every year
this first two games you go he's really
not that bad I don't know why they play
Frank Gore over Kenyan Drake I don't
have faith in any of their receivers
against some of these corners yeah I'm
going 250 dollars on
[Applause]
God there go my eardrums we got to find
the real one for that Nick okay okay but
I I definitely see what you're saying
we're so of the something that's above
the three nine and a half games yeah
you're scared by the Raiders and the
Dolphins but you're not afraid of the
Seahawks no I went a little bit more
there well I mean well I was scared of
the Seahawks look I all of them I don't
know no but you took you took the Rams
and chargers I know you took all in the
cup I did I took them all the cover
I just litter it on the chargers 50 on
the Rams 50 on it I just didn't feel
great I don't feel great about the
Packers with big point spreads because
again like oh no I I'm regretting this
like immediately but but I also I mean
it's just there's too many unknowns with
that I could see the Dolphins imploding
I don't think you're stupid here with
that logic cold weather for these real
thing too I look at the Packers and I go
are they really gonna fall two three
five and one
are they really gonna get eliminated
like I look at this and go leaving this
week or the Dolphins gonna be six and
four and the Packers gonna be three five
and one or the Dolphins five and five
course that's not arguing we know that
right and I think that Rodgers is gonna
come out like a ball of fire and I think
that the Dolphins have a play a pretty
good defense though but they have
opportunities to take big shots and I'm
just hoping that the Packers take big
shots and they bludgeon them yeah but I
you know what that's I pulled $50 away
from this and put it on the next game
because I got a little bit nervous but
apparently not nervous enough so Aaron
Rodgers save my bat safety all right
guys Sunday Night Football this week the
three and five Dallas Cowboys on the
road visiting the four and four
Philadelphia Eagles spread in this game
Philly minus seven it opened at Philly
minus four and a half and it has moved
to seven weather in Philadelphia on
Sunday high of 46 mm Sims okay um I
think it breaks down like this I mean
first of all the Dallas offense
what is it I don't know I don't know I
don't know I I think hey the first thing
is yakin dalla the first thing I always
say is can Dallas run the ball nope nope
they're not gonna run the ball on the
Philadelphia Eagles who've had a bye
week and they realize that Dallas is
coming to town they see the chance that
they hold man we could still win the NFC
East in fact we're gonna win the NFC s
and we could put Dallas you know out of
their misery right here and they're
watching the film and going damn as long
as we stop this old line and Zeek
then we should win this game and I just
have a hard time thinking that they
won't slow that running game down hey
Amari Cooper is a factor certainly but I
don't think the office is creative
enough to expose anything stupid that
you guys could or might do you know one
or two times a game on the Philadelphia
Eagles secondary I also go to the other
side of the ball now I look at the
Dallas Cowboys defense it's still a very
good defense this this is you know let's
not forget this is gonna be in a very
emotional game for the Cowboys this is
it this is really like kind of the
season for them right here but again I
just go man there's no way Dallas is
Dean line is just gonna ruin this
football game
you know the Eagles offensive line is
still good now they got another weapon
with Carson Wentz I think that you know
I have faith that the Philadelphia
Eagles coaches through the bye week
figured out a few things as far as how
they want to attack going forward I have
faith in the Eagles I don't know what it
what else to say so after saying all
that I'm putting $100 on the Eagles yeah
but a road to victory and again like
like you know I wanted to go hard here I
wanted to and I picked the Eagles to win
28 to 17 which would have them covering
the spread by four points but
desperation with a bunch of badass mofos
on the other side scares me I get you so
that's where I get scared you know it's
Zack Martin you had one in twenty eight
seven twenty at 17 I got a one in twenty
nine 16 years for the deal Sean leaves
out four to six weeks Connor Williams
was gonna miss this game he might need
surgery I know they're not really asked
what was the surgery what is it they on
his knee it is the name I'd recommend
that they move Lyle
kahlan's - left guard and play Cameron
Fleming at right tackle I think that's
the logical move but instead they're
trying out two guys at left guard look
lyle columns played left guard for two
years let's go let's get the interior
line of the Cowboys going that's just
the left go recommendation no I think
that's a very solid recommendation
actually I'm actually I didn't even know
this aspect of it so I'm actually
looking going wait so yeah they're gonna
do that and then what are they who are
they were they working out well what are
they gonna do random jabroni so your
five best guys on the field so wait
they're gonna try to put like Xavier soo
a filo or like a Looney I don't know
Looney Senna they can't do that so
they're gonna put Xavier so I feel like
our Savior so a Fela what guard Wright
and Fletcher Cox is on top of them
yeah I don't care what the Cowboys try
to do an offense and it's not going to
work yeah Lane Johnson's going to play
and all week the payee goals have been
talking about what this rivalry means to
them Jason Kelsey called out Cowboys
fans Malcolm Jenkins talked about the
history they're all talking about it the
Cowboys are not going to creep up on the
Eagles the Eagles went to London had a
bye saw their opportunity and went let's
go on a run and it starts with bashing
the Cowboys yeah the Cowboys beat the
Eagles last game of the year Nate Sud
Feld played the game before that Eagles
won by 28 game before that Eagles won by
14 Eagles have been going on a run and I
know that this could this is more this
is the Eagles run starter more than it
is the Cowboys bounce-back I got $100 on
the Eagles 29:16 want you to know
that the Cowboys are gonna D e a d e
goals are the best you can put it on
your chest chest just they got whence
they got outshine jos h fe n dr ike ck
yes my name you were spelling yes I just
think that our jo fs8 to shower and ie I
K III just I can see the Eagles putting
that final nail in the coffin that's
what this feels like
yeah right would you say the score was
twenty nine sixteen twenty nine and
sixteen yeah yeah I hear you I don't I
just hey back game the Packers game
I just chickened out there's just
something about it I didn't like to go
hard how much money do you put on that
one hundred same as you just a hundred
okay I thought for some reason you want
more all right
final game of the week Monday Night
Football the one at 7:00 New York Giants
on the road visiting the 2 & 7 San
Francisco 49ers spread in this game
49ers minus three weather in Santa Clara
on Monday 75 and sunny Sims ratings
grabber ratings grabber nice game Monday
so I'd like to hear that weather on that
day I said Monday oh I think it says
weather I mean it's the same weather
every day it's 75 degrees in sunny but
Monday it is 75 degrees okay
okay mm-hmm I guess I go if we start
with the Giants offense first the 49ers
defense I mean obviously the 49ers
defense is not like a special group but
they have some redeeming qualities that
I like you know the the Giants right
side of the defensive line it's
offensive line excuse me it sucks no
other way to put that the 49ers do have
the capability to steamroll offensive
lines at times they really do they got
some big dudes up there you know the to
tree trunks from Oregon or good Solomon
Thomas these around the ball you know 98
what is it Blair he does a good job I
mean they they will come at you and
collapse a pocket that scares me for the
Giants but I also would say on the flip
side of that what scares me too a little
bit in this matchup for the 49ers
defense versus the Giants offenses the
49ers can be
aggressive and their coverages at time
and man I'd be careful about being too
aggressive because I really think the
only way the Giants can stay in this
game for the most part you know hey
maybe they can run the ball a little bit
but I don't not gonna put too much money
on that but I do think it's through
matchup football I mean come on
say Quan one-on-one with any linebacker
or Odell or Sterling Shepard one-on-one
with some of these corners you know I
think that gives the Giants an
opportunity a few times so maybe make a
few plays than that in that you know
capacity I think when I flip it over to
the other side and the Giants defense
you know the Giants defense can be
creative and stymie use at times with
past defense and things like that
because they're a little unorthodox and
the things they do but the Giants run
defense stinks mmm and I always get into
concern when I see a run defense that
stinks that has to play against Kyle
Shannon because he is the master of the
run game and the master he is the master
and he has a PhD and how to run outside
inside zone and once he does that you
know it just becomes oh gosh damn we got
to stop the run and oh crap there's a
20-yard in cutoff a play-action and oh
there's Pierre Garcon wide open after a
bootleg and that's where the 49ers
really gets you I have no faith in the
Giants and Eli Manning to get it done I
have to see it a few more times because
they will move the ball and then all of
a sudden hit throw an interception or
he'll be backed up and for the first
time all day he'll decide to have guts
then and then try to throw the ball and
do a tight window and that'll get
intercepted so all those things bother
me and I am putting $50 on the 49ers or
the Niners
[Music]
already Niners my friend is dynamite
Shanno mike shanin am i so but I picked
this game to be a push really I picked
those diners to win 27 to 24 and I'm
only putting $50 because these two teams
are not good and I don't trust anybody
and we've got ourselves a Monday Night
Football a Sims is taking the side of
his best friend Kyle Shanahan the
bucking bronco he thinks he's gonna run
all over the juji juji man but here
comes that him left Cole you sound like
the guy you know that narrates Big
Lebowski friends with Odell Beckham jr.
yes Lee Kuan Barstow southerners in this
game but you went south it's okay little
Odell Beckham's from down in Louisiana
got himself kind of an accent
occasionally Adam left go thinks that
the Niners are gonna win this game by
the pulcher a difference of one point he
sees them when in 2219 with Odell
Beckham and sukwon Barkley putting on
quite the show with Nick Mullens
struggling to Joe tessitura going oh
maybe next time Adam left Coe would like
to put $40 on the New York 42 tentative
and that's a real crowd right there let
me tell you something gives me chills a
man who's gonna win this game yeah was
the guest on Sims and left go : the show
Landon Collins arey goes is his heart
battle in the show that's how you read
it Sims and left go : the show I think
that the Giants might even pull the
upset in this one Sims that's why I'm
putting 40 buckaroo knees oh you
dangerously don't break the bank take
the spank $40 yeah this is a bad scary
game it's a crab oh that was that was
your breakdown yeah okay
that's the end of the show that's it
anything else you want to say about
Monday Night Football
all right so what do we disagree on all
right so the big disagreements from this
week 150 points wing on Detroit Chicago
yep a hundred and fifty points wing on
Kansas City Arizona yep a 60 point swing
on Buffalo and the Jets you better you
better
I bet $10 on the gym okay no you bet a
hundred of Kansas you've got a hundred
dollars on the Lions yes
and then you disagree on Monday Night
Football and no there's a hundred and
fifty points wing on Seattle and the
Rams cuz you took the Rams and I took
Seattle you bet all of the nine and a
half point teams to cover which I did
happy I bet against one of them
hopefully Sims is too big bets 300 bucks
on New Orleans minus five and a half
Atlanta 300 bucks on a Falcons minus
four and then left go you have 300 on
the Chargers 200 on the Jaguars and 250
on the Packers and for my left Cole ox
I'm gonna make two of mine and two of
yours I'm gonna make a left Cole lockout
of the Jacksonville Jaguars because I'm
a sicko that's the game I can get right
down I'm rooming with the Colts now
great I'm making it a left cold lock
because why not let's have fun on this
old buckaroo
I'm gonna make the Chargers a left go
lock at nine and a half yeah I'm gonna
make the Falcons a left go luck
compliments as seems and I'm gonna make
this Saint so left go alive hope you
don't mush me you know what if I'm mush
yeah I'll take it
you've just been left go along you know
what time it is left alright it is time
to enter a world of not chance but of
guaranteed decisions five and Oh last
week five and oh the week before five
and oh the week before that he's 19 and
won in the last four weeks it's five
teams guaranteed to lose the Oracle
Chris Simms but Chris we must uphold
tradition this is the official music of
the Oracle but it's not the official
music of guaranteed to lose Simms give
it to us okay some people call them the
Bengals that I called the Bengals and
they're gonna lose you know why cuz
they're playing against the saints and
the saints are really awesome and I
don't trust anything about the
Cincinnati Bengals hey Sims it's week
ten
do you believe of course I don't believe
in the bronze not there the calves stink
the Browns stink it's dysfunctional as
always and the Falcons are red heart hot
[Music]
to lose you really don't have to say
anything because we believe you come on
let's just make this short and to the
point
Cardinals verse Chiefs no chance
sorry Cardinals I know you'll give a
spirited effort but Patrick mahomes and
the Chiefs are amazing
alright Sims let's go down to the Music
City dial me up a tune for who's next to
Lou oh it's Bray ball and peas verse 30
there's their arch nemesis Bill
Belichick and the New England Patriots
Oh what can they do
oh they can lose cuz New England's
better and a more complete team and been
on fire for like the last seven weeks
and that's Marcus Mariota and I don't
know what to expect for their offense so
you know why you're gonna lose Tennessee
alright and Alessa
the last team guaranteed to lose Sims if
you could do it the voice of your old
coach I'd really a
yeah I can't do it I can't it sounds
like beavis and butt-head when I do it
sorry writers you're gonna lose you're a
dumpster fire the Chargers are for real
this year maybe you give a spirit of
effort maybe you lose by 38 but I know
one thing you're going to lose I
guarantee it
and there you go the five teams call
your bookie make them cry because you
support that weird Sims guy
Bengals Browns Raiders Titans and
Cardinals I go back to the Oracle music
I like that better next week I want to
do article you want to do it like this I
do know now you're on a heater one eye I
didn't want to ruin it I wanted to make
sure you right because because you have
just left guaranteed to lose this is my
kind of music writer Christopher Sims do
you think he'll go five I know this week
I feel pretty good look at the paper
look at the ball no no I actually
thought there was like maybe too many
teams that I get guarantee this week it
was actually like don't be cocky don't
get cocky
well come on you guys see it I mean you
know Dallas you could have picked them
for guaranteed to lose right I mean we
probably would have both picked the
Miami Dolphins guarantee Drew's right
all of us all three of us the Seattle
Seahawks against the Rams
you're not guaranteeing I mean I didn't
either but it's it's in there it was in
the possibility you're trying to give
people an eight-team parlay no I'm just
saying those teams went through my
thought but the five I pick I think man
if I don't go at least four and one
there I mean I don't even know which one
I would say would be the one to be
scared of I think you're going three and
two you think I'm going three and two
yeah hopefully it's not the $2,000 for
Simms peace out homey Fenric says good
evening everybody
have a LEF koe
[Music]
and for Niki gr grunting - Gandhi ji R
grande let it go Niki jeoldae gia grande
guys good luck on your bets if you're
making them good luck if your money
lining and parlaying sims is guaranteed
to lose super super super luck to you
and we will holla holla holla at you
later enjoy the games